welcome to this video more more down 34
and it doesn't show why doesn't it show
a statistic it seems I think I'm played
him right no I didn't huh could have
sworn that I have played this guy beard
okay so gotta reti opening and let's
let's see I want to play this default
line that I recently used with success I
really stunned I'm totally sure I have
played him but it's not in the statistic
somehow yeah okay efore is what I'm
would I like to play wait the guy only
has 22 games what did I did her what she
game of him maybe against kingscrusher
know yeah it's a kind of kinda weird
when you are totally sure you have
played someone and it says some it's not
the case yeah unfortunately this cost a
little bit of time but it's okay it
happens yeah this line i recently had in
a in a in a blitz game and i had
explained then that i believe that black
has to be quite cautious with his pawn
breaks he has played c5 though so let's
see i can play night h4 here to gain the
bishop am
yeah let's do that yeah just getting
getting the pair of bishops and go from
there okay now i have g5 as an
interesting option it's not necessary
but interesting is also queen queen bee
three is also SS Bishop e3 mmhmm yeah
yeah got got some options here g5 is
going to play a 5 yeah but it's not bad
'if I've aged 44 h 5 hmm you're
interesting he basically has to has to
play five taking taking just opens up
the whole position for my bishops you
five is only move him okay sometimes
hard too hard too hard to get moves by a
bear opponents hmm not be seven hangs
and Ruby one is also a thread so it's
also a concrete problem I mean besides
the fact that this is strategically
horrible to take on d5 it see also seems
to technically fail I you really don't
see how he keeps miss material now after
a five I had a player play age form so
he's giving up one pawn that's a
relatively best decision I guess trying
to activate at least here the rook on
the B file it's still no pain not not
sufficient compensation
yes so how am I going to do that b2 is
their own name and that's the weakness
but it is a weakness I can play rookie
to maybe up from the Bishop e3
development if he goes rook e8 I can
trade them yeah that's okay so Bishop e3
yeah probably okay I can also just
protect him or move it yeah 93 it's not
really a problem now 87 is hanging so I
don't really know if he has the time to
play a move like 93
okay so yeah so also rookie one is a
move that looks kind of looks good right
attacking the bishop ok and now Bishop
f4 I am getting Bishop Bishop c5
I def three bishops e7 this is a win and
I don't know what he's doing rookie
eight maybe but then rookie one is
coming f6 Bishop g5 check yeah okay it's
not easy I mean white has a white has a
range of good end games to two get have
to decide which one check yeah this is
one possible endgame attacking here
that's the question I can take I can
take you five and then see 442 pounds it
is opposite colored bishops but it is
also still very good so be three keeps
us protected and I come to the
seventh-ranked shortly
look 25 is also
check
it's always debatable do you want to
take a pawn and accept the opposite
colored bishops and some yeah it's
something that's tricky but yeah I'm
pretty confident because of the
excellent activity that that white has
so I'm going to check here and now push
the pawns we should be five takes a form
is going to happen okay takes is got g5
okay take special be 50 now that wasn't
so precise really thought g5 okay but
let me take the pawns IAM time morning
mmm gallery I thought g5 was was much
more testing
now probably am it's almost always a bad
idea to to get two opposite colored
bishops probably I should have avoided
that as well I know they're just too fun
too far advanced check checkmate yeah
okay there are 22 interesting moments in
this game first of all of course here
where e 5 is just just the only move and
he didn't do that it simply must be
played regardless of how good it is but
it is just the only move yeah I thought
that intended h4 in this position h4 h5
of course I can also just play C form
but the thing is this is a protected
passer and usually nice but it is quite
well blockaded it's not so not so clear
how I'm going to ya make it count an
important point is that a typical
counter players f5 but this is something
that black has to be cautious with in a
way as g6 here this this this formation
is weakened see he has to play am still
a 5 I thought I mean I wanted to go here
intending this Knight f6 and then Bishop
g5 this kind of thing was what I was
roughly calculating or thinking about
yeah this is just just just lost now 25
his he's losing very important b7 porn
and rookie one is some is an additional
threat but this is also strategically
just wrong opening up the long diagonal
here it is a it is some also forced
problem they're just winning or just
giving away upon I think I'm the
technical part was was basically okay at
first here I'm just keeping you know
yeah I'm just keeping a big edge Bishop
f4 yeah and this is this is a question
it probably is objectively winning Jack
grabbing grabbing this pawn but it it
sometimes makes things tricky and not
sure if if this was the absolute best
one but check you know what was probably
not so great an idea was to take him
when he when he got g5 and like here
here yes to go gif and here I wasn't
entirely sure how easy that is um Bishop
b5 is the move that irritates me a lot I
mean in a somewhat unlucky spot here
like here should be 5c four
I cannot take because I'm promoting now
it's probably just about winning but it
wasn't hmm it wasn't really necessary to
do that it was easier to keep one pair
of rooks on all I have to make sure that
there's a pawn on f4 like you p h4 yeah
it's easier not to trade rooks
definitely okay i hope you enjoyed this
thanks for watching